well we kick off this newshour with a
developing breaking story for you
federal prosecutors in the united states
in the last hour or so have arrested and
charged a former senior white house
strategist he's steve bannon
he was one of president trump's most
influential advisors
during the 2016 election campaign the
justice department is accusing him
of conspiracy to commit wire fraud it
has to do with a fundraising campaign to
support the building of donald trump's
wall
along the border between the u.s and
mexico live now
to the heart of the story the white
house and our correspondent there
kimberly halkit kim hi there so mr
bannon what does this mean
uh well what this means is that he could
face along with his associates up to 20
years in prison these are not light uh
indictments that he is facing uh what
this
is is an allegation a very serious one
at that that
this was nothing more than a scheme an
online scheme to fund lavish lifestyles
under the pretense
of building the president's border wall
that donors grassroots donors
often donating very small sums thought
that they were giving money to
participate in the
construction of a wall but instead what
the indictment says
is that steve bannon and his associates
then created
shell companies phony invoices and phony
vendors in order to funnel the money
to themselves so this is certainly a
serious indictment
at the same time this is another problem
for the u.s president given the fact
that this is yet another member of his
inner circle that has been charged with
very serious crimes you'll remember his
former campaign manager paul manafort he
was of course convicted
of unrelated fraud charges so this is
something that the president will have
to
explain now at the same time peter we
should point out
that steve bannon was only in the white
house for about seven months there was a
falling out
particularly the president pushing back
after steve bannon sharply criticized
his children particularly ivanka trump
the president very fond of her steve
bannon calling her
dumb as a brick so no love lost between
these two men
uh we're waiting very for the president
who will be meeting with the iraqi prime
minister very shortly that's why you see
the color guard
behind me we expect that he may have
something to say
about this indictment of steve bannon
his former chief strategist
let's talk about that visit of mr
academy the iraqi prime minister
where is that relationship at the moment
yeah well there's a sort of an interest
in this in the united states as well as
from iraq because there's
again no love lost between the united
states and iraq when it comes to the
fact that
it's been 17 years now since the u.s
invaded iraq
a lot of people not just here in the
united states but of course also in iraq
don't really want to see
u.s troops inside iraq and that's really
what the focus of this meeting is going
to be about the future of those u.s
troops there of course we know that
inside iraq that there are many
particularly iran-backed factions that
do
not want those soldiers there
particularly after the u.s and its drone
strike that killed
the iranian commander kasim sulaimani so
uh
well they say that this is going to be
able an opportunity to talk these two
leaders donald trump and also the iraqi
prime minister about economics
culture and education what they're
really zeroing
in on is the future of u.s soldiers
there the u.s is going to make the
argument
we want to keep them there a bit longer
as a deterrent to iran
and of course as iraq is a major oil
producing nation the us has interest
there
as well okay kimberly uh we'll come back
to you and we'll also come back to that
news conference that we understand is
going to kick off in the next few hours
bruce spine
is formerly a u.s associate deputy
attorney general he joins us on skype
from washington bruce great to have you
here on the program again
so mr bannon what's your big takeaway
point on that
well i think it shows that the idea that
mr trump and his
associates were going to drain the swamp
was just another piece of hypocrisy
it's not just mr bannon isolation the
entire trump administration is filled
with characters including the president
himself and his family
who have employed government and their
prominence in order to profit
personally whether it's selling
trademarks or merchandise or
attracting foreigners to attend hotels
and things of that sort
so the president set the standard that's
pretty low here it was rather raw he
just
looted a fund that was purportedly
created to build a private wall with
mexico
which was again building off of a trump
initiative
which the experts say will do nothing to
diminish illegal immigration
uh and then turning that endeavor into a
private profit-making
uh venture for mr bannon and his
co-conspirators there
okay is there potentially here however a
huge political problem for the trump
administration and it's this you know
roger stone is a free man we've seen
people involved in illegality at the
beginning of or at the end of the
campaign the beginning of the presidency
and they in effect have walked away from
the tariff that they had
to pay but this legal process will
straddle
the us election of course it will and
maybe the inauguration
by several months because we're what 10
weeks away now nine weeks away
from november the third
i would agree but i think that the
public now is
almost jaded by the wrong doing of the
trump administration i don't know what
additional increment that the bannon
arrest provides
i think when we spoke this morning
before the arrest
most people would think it was a corrupt
administration
uh paul manafort is a is just one
instance but he had squat scott pruitt
and many members of the administration
who had to leave under ethical clouds
the secretary of health and human
services the secretary of labor
uh mr trump himself being sued under the
emoluments clause
he's got a his private communications
secretary
promoting ivanka trump goods uh you know
with white house
property all these illegalities are so
rampant
uh there already was a cynicism built in
and i think
although o'bannon arrests an indictment
adds to it
uh i don't know how much the increment
is uh
it already is an administration that is
tainted by three and a half
almost four years now of using
government for private enrichment
okay when we talk about private
enrichment your area of expertise bruce
is basically things that are legal and
illegal and
in in that area also finances or illegal
financing
of schemes such as this one we're
talking here about a fund that
reportedly according to msnbc was worth
25
million dollars surely there are checks
and balances surely if people put money
in
or take money out they've got to run it
through a firm of accountants to say
can we do this at which point somebody
says no you can't because that's
hello that's illegal
well that's true but here apparently the
scheme was they just created phony
invoices
uh and then paid themselves uh i it's
the same kind of thing that we've seen
in adjacent
organizations the national rifle
association it's a very
inbred incestuous situation
where people are policing themselves
they're not going through proper
accounting standards
and end up turning the the what so to be
uh public
i mean uh public investors into just uh
tools for their own
enrichment um and i do think that's what
we had here
they just invented invoices uh
fraudulently created them
that's what roger stone was famous for
too he would invent polls and
all sorts of things uh in his dirty
tricks campaigns
and uh i think this is going to be a
very clear-cut case if
they just stole the money it's just a
little more sophisticated than willie
sutton stealing money from banks
bruce share with us your thoughts as
well we understand in the last hour or
so mr trump has gone to court he's
appealing against
what's going on with the taxation story
will that go in his favor or will that
go against him
well i think the tax issue is going to
go against him it's a usurpation of the
congressional authority over taxation uh
i don't think that he doesn't even have
uh the kind of uh authority that he's
hopes
would increase the uh the actual
uh salaries of those who would so-called
defer
their social security taxes for an
indefinite period
uh i think it's a huge huge flaw it was
a gesture
that will show a cynicism where many
people are
suffering with covet 19. he's basically
preaching
it'll go away on its own don't worry in
the short run i'll try to give you a few
extra dollars
uh but i don't think that's going to
pass muster i think his effort to shore
up the covet 19 failure
with these small efforts illegal as they
are
uh will be politically worthless to him
okay we must leave it there bruce fine
in the states many thanks thank you